nouveau batman nouvel acteur dans la
peau du justicier masqué le britannique
robert pattinson
avant robert pattinson ils sont sept
acteurs à avoir jouer batman au cinéma
le 1er luis wilson en 1943 puis adam
west en 1966 dans un magnifique costume
ensuite plus rien jusqu'en 1989
l'américain michael keaton enfile le
costume dans le batman de tim burton a
un sens
le film est un carton planétaire
l'acteur incarnera une seconde fois le
super héros en 1992 dans batman le défi
toujours de tim burton
quatrième batman val kilmer dans batman
forever de joel schumacher
c'était en 1995 un film plus coloré plus
moderne que son prédécesseur
quand vous poussez ce jeune homme nanti
il a tout l'argent qui le désirent et
pourtant la nuit il va combattre le
crime il a choisi de le faire enfin
choisi pas vraiment c'est quelque chose
qui s'impose à lui
l'aventuré batman ne va pas plus loin
pour val kilmer l'acteur ne tourne qu'à
un seul film en 1997 il cède sa place à
georges clooney dans batman et robin
toujours de joel schumacher
salut les frises je suis batman à la
sortie du film petite confidence de
george clooney à la télé jouer dans un
costume en latex n'a pas été facile pour
le comédien
l'astuce quand vous abordez ce rôle
c'est de savoir que vous ne pouvez plus
compter sur vos oreilles
la concentration se fait donc à un autre
niveau
vous avez des millions de dollars effets
spéciaux qui s'agitent pendant que vous
parlez c'est vraiment troublant le film
est démolie par la critique et déçoit au
box-office
huit ans plus tard en 2005
un nouvel acteur se glisse dans la peau
de batman christian bale
au total il fera trois films tous des
cartons il ya deux sas aide en lui il ya
le côté altruiste généreux hérité de ses
parents et de l'autre le côté sombre de
raji non violent
après kristen bell ben affleck a aussi
joué le rôle de batman dans quatre films
dernier batman en date robert pattinson
c'est le 8ème acteur à incarner le
personnage de dc comics cinéma à ses
côtés l'actrice américaine zoé kravitz
dans le rôle de catwoman ou encore
l'irlande et colin farrell dans la peau
du redoutable pingouins
[Musique]